بين كواليس الحرب الاوكرانيه الدائره
يتردد حديث في الدبلوماسيه والمفاوضات
الولايات المتحده الداعم الكبير لكي يوفر
رئيسها يبدو ان مسؤوليها بداوا دفع فريق
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه للتفكير بعقد محادثات
سلام مع موسكو تحسبا لتعثر التقدم
الميداني وفقدان الزخم المتحقق حاليا على
الارض مع حلول فصل الشتاء كبار المسؤولين
الامريكيين بداوا يتساءلون بشكل علنيا عن
حجم الاراضي التي يمكن كسبها وباي تكلفه
وفقه ما نقلت صحيفه
يجب ان يكون هناك اقرار متبادل بان النصر
قد يتعذر تحقيقه من خلال الوسائل العسكريه
لذلك نحتاج الى اللجوء الى وسائل اخرى
ووفقا لصحيفه الامريكيه فان الحديثه في
واشنطن عن تحولات محتمله في الحرب بدا مع
اقتراب فصل الشتاء وزياده المخاوف من
ارتفاع معدلات التضخم الناتج عن ارتفاع
اسعار الطاقه والغذاء الى جانب سقوط عشرات
الالاف من الضحايا من الجانبين فضلا عن
مليارات الدولارات من المساعدات الامريكيه
التي تم ضخها الى كياف حيث لا فتاه
الصحيفه الى ان الولايات المتحده وبعض
خلفائها يشعرون بالقلق من استنزاف
مخزوناتهم من الاسلحه بمعدل لا يمكن تحمله
مضيفه ان الدعم العسكريه الامريكيه
لاوكرانيا هذا العام والذي بات يقترب من
19 مليار دولار يفوق المساعدات الاوروبيه
بكثير
وبحسب ما نقالته عن اشخاص المطالعين على
المناقشات فان نواصم اوضحت لاوكرانيا انك
تحتاج على الاقل لان تبدو منفتحه على حل
مضيء وهي الرساله التي نقلها مستشار الامن
القومي الامريكي جاك سوليفان الى الرئيس
الاوكراني خلال زيارته الاخيره لكيف
ملوك الشيخ العربيه